the kids bugging you he puts his hands
on you you pick up the nearest rock or
whatever you can get your hands on and
you lay them out so you can save
yourself lucky very lucky but you have
to tell him to meet the luck right
somebody hands you the ball and you run
so ambition was a dirty word to me
because it felt like you were working
for some gang or material he's widely
regarded as one of the world's biggest
film stars he rose to prominence in his
role in a 1980s TV series 21 Jump Street
where he quickly became a teen idol he
was listed in the 2012 Guinness Book of
World Records as the highest-paid actor
earning over 75 million dollars he's
Johnny Depp and here is my take on his
top ten rules of success rule number one
is our personal favorite and make sure
to stick around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips and you
guys know the drill if you hear
something that Johnny says it really
inspires you please leave it in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
if if we could celebrate every breath
that we take because nothing's a
guarantee if we could celebrate the
breath and the exhale which is being
alive without you know my car won't
start
oh geez you know the cat drop dead hey
you know I think I need a lobotomy you
know uh I mean there are things that are
very very important in life that we we
just we don't think about you know and
then one of the most worrisome things
that I went through four years is you
freaked a freaked out about your past
you're worried you're scared to death of
the future and that's all you're
thinking about but then now doesn't
exist you know and I think that's a
grave mistake that we make one of the
greatest pieces of advice I've ever
gotten in my life was from my mom you
know when I was a little kid there was a
kid who was bugging me you know in
school and she said okay I'm gonna tell
you what to do she said the kids bugging
you he puts his hands on you you pick up
the nearest rock or whatever you can get
your hands on and you lay him out
than I did and I felt better and it
worked and so for me you know that that
was a great lesson because someone had
invaded my myspace and dated my being
you know and I was doing something
against me that I didn't want to be done
so I took control the situation and I
ran with it and and many years later
after being you know turned into a
product you know by a very huge
corporation that had their hands all
over me and I and I couldn't escape it
you know I promised myself that I would
continue to move forward and do my best
not to compromise in any way whatsoever
you know not not allow anyone to put
their hands on me and affect me in that
way so that's the best advice I think I
could give is just to keep moving
forward and don't don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody thinks you know just keep moving
forward and do what you have to do
you Paul Newman told me that any
successful person in any field who in
discussing their career doesn't use the
word walk is a lotta oh yeah he's
absolutely right yeah so you consider
yourself lucky very lucky but you have
to have talent to meet the luck right
somebody hands you the ball and you run
you know I mean and if you get hit you
get hit or maybe you make it through you
never know but I mean I I just know that
somebody handed me the ball of a certain
point and I was hungry enough to keep
running and I'm still running I maintain
a hunger but not an ambition you know I
I I'm very happy to explore all
possibilities for the character and and
really you know dive in to to the role I
mean even to the point of where you know
Disney wanted to want to fire me they
wanted to fire you from Pirates yeah
because they couldn't understand what I
was doing you know they didn't
understand the character they were
actually were contemplating subtitling
the film you know and you went to play
music when you quit school you didn't go
to become an actor well I'd already it
was already place I started playing the
guitar at the age of 12 I felt a passion
for it that yeah it was the first real
passion that I that I that I had and I
and I can safely say because I feel and
I felt then that the word ambition has
become dirty you know yeah because I'm
Bishan somehow implies that the result I
know I know
[Laughter]
I'll probably be crying about today so
ambition was a dirty word to me because
it felt like you were working for some
gang or a material or some status or so
I literally don't remember going through
puberty uh because I locked myself in a
room at the
12 12 13 and just played the guitar I
learned things off records and taught
myself how to play and it was my life
and it was the only solace it was the
only sanctuary it was the only security
it was the it was my first love at the
end of our session yesterday you said
thank you to Scott for reviving my
career and I don't know if that's ingest
because I've never had the impression
that you you're desperate for box office
but that you came forth absolutely it's
been my it's been the thrust of my of my
interests since day one when I was about
19 yeah so I care about 20 years of
failures will do that to you but on a
different level why do you say that and
how do you feel when you choose a role
that ends up satisfying you that this
one clearly did well you know for me
with every character that you play you
know as as long as you've reached that
you've arrived at that place where you
believe is is the right place to be for
the character and if you feel that
you've done service to the to the
director to yourself to the author then
to me to me that's a success the box
office is kind of you know that's
something else that's not certainly none
of my business you know I mean once the
one son raps on a film it's just say
goodbye to the character and then move
forward how ironic is it that you know
you as I said you know you can get
pumping gas when I was pumping gas most
definitely printing t-shirts and selling
ink pens and you know I'm gonna have
every anything anything and everything
yeah and then the fact that you have a
20 to 20 year career of failures and
then you do a pirate movie and that buys
you
island is pretty Amin your any of that
is pretty do you think about the times
when things weren't so good a lot yeah
yeah oh yeah but I you know there was a
guy who I worked with many years ago and
we were talking about success and money
and all that stuff and he told me this
one thing he said you know money doesn't
change anybody money reveals them you
know same thing with success and I
believe that you know wholeheartedly I
think I've been revealed I don't think I
haven't changed I said I'm still exactly
the guy that used to pump gas you know
I'm still the guy that was a mechanic
for a minute you monster
exactly I just happen to have a weird
weirder job at the moment when I was
approaching the character of Willy Wonka
I you know we all grew up with the gene
Wilder version and it's in it's
fantastic I mean yeah it's fantastic but
you know I mean why go in that direction
it's been done why repeat why so I found
my own version and my version was I kept
thinking of children's television hosts
that scared me because yeah we there
were unpredictable you know and and they
had that very everything was okay and
and it wasn't okay but so so so I use
these children's television hosts sort
of ideas and then the other ingredient
that I thought was was really what found
the character
I thought of george w bush
[Applause]
if he weren't readily stoned like not
just uncomfortably stoned it passed what
could have been the uncomfortable
paranoia states with her
each assert doesn't know what he's
saying
okay Mad Hatter um the the the Mad
Hatter was basically a kind of uh yeah
Mikey this is real weird so my kids had
a tutor we were on the road you know I'm
working in something guys so they had
this tutor perhaps Katherine and she was
one of those English people very proper
but Katherine would talk to you
[Music]
so i sponged her up as much as I could
because what I loved about her was she
would she would sort of talk to you like
this you know and the rate it's one of
those people who like you know it's
something that they avert their eyes
they actually close their eyes when
they're looking at you right you guys
have felt that before it's weird
so so I used because when she arrived
she I mean every
[Applause]
she'll find this out tomorrow and
probably there'll be a lawsuit there
were the things that I probably should
have done not from my perspective I mean
from my point of view I did the right
things every every film that I've done
I'm happy that I that I made that choice
I don't have any regrets whatsoever but
I mean in terms of a sustaining a box
office you know bankability I should
have done a few other things that I
didn't do but I'm glad I didn't do them
me know because it wouldn't have been
you yeah well I would it would have been
for the wrong reasons
I did everything that I've been lucky
enough to do I did for the right reasons
you have to realize that whatever your
day is whatever you're doing whatever
your job is whatever people think of you
or project you to be none of it matters
really until you look round and see
people who who are in need and I think
the probably the best finit benefit of
my job is to to help to make people
smile who otherwise wouldn't or couldn't
have a smile on their face so yeah
that's my ideal I saw crazy hard and I
saw Jeff Bridges who is obviously a
brilliant brilliant actor
and is capable of so much but what I saw
in Jeff Bridges was so brave and so and
and the only way that one can arrive at
that arena is because you have a
director who's brave and is open to like
I said the idea of chance and Scott and
I I mean talked about working together I
was desperate to work with the guy and
beyond anything I've ever experienced I
just never I've never experienced a
director like this he doesn't allow the
audience to to feel the camera to notice
the camera he makes the camera breathe
as if it's another person you never
really noticed it's not like these fancy
kind of shots I mean he he would do huge
huge scenes with a lot of people in a
water and it was so freeing and so
magnificent to play that because you
have this extended period of time where
it's almost like you know you've got
seven minutes of a play almost it blew
me away I'm thinking this is this guy's
third film it's his third film and he's
a master like he's a master it really is
me
[Music]
Trulli and if if phone books still
existed I would shoot I would film the
phone book with the man thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
I made this video because holistic negev
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also really
love to know what did Johnny say that
really left a mark on you what was the
biggest lesson that you took from this
that you will immediately apply to your
life or business leave it in the
comments I'm gonna join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to jennifer price
Jennifer thank you so much for picking
up a cup of my book and posting it on
Facebook I really really really
appreciate it so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
this is like a madness or brilliance
remark about how often those tears rates
coincide there's crazy there's insanity
there's delirium there's I mean it but I
but it's only to me it's only madness or
maybe a touch of insanity that that you
the one can access and to be aware of it
growing up doesn't it didn't feel
particularly great but um I think it's
led me somehow to where I am today I'm
not saying that I'm completely that I'm
completely mad although I've been
accused of that many times over the
years but I don't know I hope that
people will if they do have that
tendency that they that they can find a
way to embrace it and use it - they're
not advantage let's say in a you know in
a
even in a creative sense I mean using a
creative sense if you can but use that
to find your way to be able to stand on
solid ground you've never seen any of
your films ever I tried to see one once
because the director asked me to remote
my wife amber can attest to this because
her elbow is very busy that night I was
sitting next to her director's wife is
here directors here I fell asleep 35
times and I got this maybe but part of
the reason is is is being in the moment
when you're acting and after I mean you
don't want to I feel the experience I'm
happy with the process is what I'm
interested in the process of creating
the process of exploring the process of
breaking formula the process of dropping
the bottom out of his scene because it
because the people can get stale yeah
and I feel it's the wrong place to be so
I'm interested and always have been
interested in trying to avoid like what
was expected and Edward Scissorhands was
certainly the the first real opportunity
for me to feel like I was standing on
firm ground cry-baby was important
Edward Scissorhands was was the first
time that I felt okay I I'm I'm solid
yeah we'll get that I can start hacking
through you know paving my way let's
show them a clip here at Johnny Public
Enemies opens July 1st and what are we
gonna see no no
what are we gonna see here I have no
idea let's take a look at a clip here
mr. Depp what are we gonna see the film
opens April 18th you know we're looking
at here this is something from the film
transcendence what is the clip here
Johnny I have no idea no for God's sake
this is beautiful this looks like a like
an old-fashioned I don't know sloop is
it a sloop or something is it a yacht
well I don't know what that is I really
don't know it's just a boat if we look
like you know what you're doing on a
horse yeah I don't I that was probably
about 2 and a half seconds before
everything went very sideways there's
two things that I have a problem with
one is that I never read screen
direction which is the stuff that tells
you what to do well I'd rather not know
what they want me to do you purchased an
island I did in fact yeah Wow I didn't I
didn't know you could you could do that
and I didn't I have you seen the movie
no if not I'm sorry you've not seen the
movie that's just yet and well you're
too busy to see it probably oh you know
in a way you know once once my job is
done on the film but it's really none of
my business
we're talking about something else
Johnny settle down God's sakes can you
keep your mind on the movie every time I
turn around
it's it's a yeah it's a lot of fun and
[Music]
that's all right father that's I think
aren't you a little curious about how
the work looks that you're doing no this
is irresponsible of me but nice going
[Applause]